unendlich nachdem der start verschoben
werden musste hob gestern nacht aus
florida die space ex der nächste shuttle
ab und das ganz ohne zwischenfälle
spacex liegt so hieß es am sonntag
startete die raumfähre cruz bergen von
unternehmer elon musk für eine mission
zur internationalen raumstation iss
die kapsel mit vier astronauten an bord
ist mit einem tag verspätung vom kennedy
space center in florida abgehoben ein
halbes jahr nach ihrem jungfernflug ist
das die erste reguläre mission für das
unternehmen
die nasa hatte ihr shuttle programm in
den letzten jahren wegen zu hoher kosten
und zwei unglücken eingestellt so dass
die amerikaner auf russische raketen
angewiesen waren
nun will spacex als erster privater
anbieter marktführer in der raumfahrt
werden die astronauten werden rund 27
stunden unterwegs sein und sollen etwa
sechs monate auf der iss bleiben
über diesen start möchte ich nun
sprechen mit dem esa chef jan wörner mir
nun zugeschaltet dann werden als ernst
natürlich die frage haben sie den start
gestern dann nachts live verfolgt ich
habe ihn ausnahmsweise mal nicht
verfolgt aber ich habe natürlich sofort
heute im frühen morgen schon ganz früh
alles nachgeschaut wie es gelaufen ist
und bin sehr erleichtert und sehr froh
dass es gut gegangen ist wissen sie
schon wann der erste deutsch oder die
erste deutsche mit der space ex dann
abheben wird also ich versuche ja immer
wieder klar zu sagen ich bin
europäischer generaldirektor und deshalb
interessieren mich die nationalität
nicht so sehr ich sage sogar immer es
gibt gar keine deutschen astronauten nur
europäische astronauten mit einem
deutschen führerschein aber tatsächlich
werden wir schon sehr bald
ich möchte erstmal in einer kapsel sehen
die von damaskus
wie wichtig ist denn jetzt überhaupt
noch das sojus projekt von den russen
jetzt wo es dann durch amerika und die
space sechs dieser alternative gibt
geopolitisch kann ich nur sagen ist es
prima wenn man west und ost sich
verbindet und wenn wir mit sojus-kapseln
fliegen wenn wir mit
amerikanischen kapseln fliegen oder
vielleicht auch in zukunft mit
chinesischen das ist geopolitisch
wichtig um über grenzen zusammen
zusammenarbeiten als ingenieur sage ich
es ist immer gut eine reserve zu haben
ein parallelsystem denn es kann immer
mal etwas passieren das wissen wir aus
dem chor den shuttle zeiten
wir wissen es auch aus den von der sojus
so ist es ist gut wenn man
parallelsystem hat wir nennen das dann
redundanz in der ingenieur sprache um
dann fortwährend die internationale
raumstation anfliegen zu können
jetzt haben sie gerade amerikanische
russische und chinesische raketen
angesprochen wann denn dann eine
europäische den flinken europäische
rakete meinen sie ja ja das wäre mein
traum ich habe das versucht vor zehn
jahren vorzuschlagen oder caps
vorgeschlagen und habe dafür aus
mehreren ländern
doch heftige prügel bezogen in europa
weil es doch sehr teuer ist aber ich
finde es weiterhin gut wenn deutschland
und europa sich auch in dem
astronomischen flügen beteiligen würde
nicht nur durch gut ausgebildete
astronauten sondern eben auch durch die
möglichkeit eines transportmittels mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren